hey I have to tell you I did not realize
how much I missed red and kitty until I
started watching that 90s show uh you
know when That 70s Show wrapped in 2006
did you ever imagine that you'd be
continuing this story in 2023
I did not not again no
no and you thought that was it was there
did you kind of want to revisit these
characters or did you feel like that was
enough with that during that time
well I love the characters uh I think we
both do
um but I I'm really quite honestly I
think I felt like this the ship had
sailed uh and a lot because the kids
careers were just
booming you know and I thought well you
know what they're off on their own
Journey now and and you know and it's
going to be a good long one so I think I
thought we did it and it was done and it
was done well and there you have it
I I wanted to keep going I wanted to do
10 years I wanted to do another two
years at least and if the kids didn't
want to do it we just tie them up and
drag them on the set
that's so red that is something red
would do yeah
um do you have to practice saying the
word dumbass to get back into character
red or does that just go naturally now I
get plenty of practice because for some
reason
young guys
come up to me and ask me to call them
I don't know I guess they give feel like
they have a little piece of this show
then they're they're a little tiny part
of the show if I do that so
so I'm happy to oblige so tell her what
you say I say
anyone who wants to be called
is a
it's very rare that when someone gets
called it feels warm and fuzzy so
yeah all right I I love that so many
members of the original cast are back I
mean who knew that Jackie and Kelso
would get married in real life so what's
it been like for you watching Mila Kunis
and Ashton Kutcher back on set together
as a married couple with two kids
well I think they're just like
two amazing humans number one and then
for them to come together
to create two more amazing humans uh is
just
gold I mean it's just it's a gift of the
Gods and uh seeing them come back uh
Kelso had it
um Ashton had it pretty much right away
but male I had to work it a couple times
to find Jackie because Jackie is so
obnoxious and she knew it but she you
know she hasn't lived in that obnoxious
world for a while she was also 14 when
she started and no yeah so it took her a
couple times but man when she found it
she found it don't you agree
did you see it it oh yes I've seen all
the episodes because I'm obsessed it's
she's so good like the tacky element too
and oh I know so
um I also couldn't stop laughing during
the entire episode with Fez Shay Fez
yeah no but he came up with that he came
up with when she when we had the we were
doing readings over Zoom you know the
initial reading because of the pandemic
and and the first time
Wilmer so it's Shea Fez but Wilbur goes
yeah Chez Fez well we died we died
because that's such a perfect Fez thing
you know that was um that was such a
happy moment for us because that just
reminded us that took us way back to 70
show you know that's something Wilmer
would do though
I love that you know it's one thing to
be back on set but when you are a
working opposite you know when your back
is red and kitty and you're back with
these characters that you worked with
for so long does it feel a little
surreal or does it feel like no time has
passed
uh kind of both you know enjoy it's
joyous it's just absolutely it's just
there's joy in it you know it's like I
remember you you know it's it's I
remember how to handle you yeah
that's amazing well congratulations uh
as a fan of the original I love the 90s
show so thank you very much thank you